[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta vladimir
putin es de izquierdas o de derechas no
sé a alguno le va a estallar la cabeza
con esta pregunta pero pensadlo bien por
un momento por un lado el estilo de
putin tiene muchos elementos que
podríamos decir que son muy
conservadores
[Música]
empezando por su oposición a los
derechos lgtb siguiendo por su retórica
ultranacionalista pero por el otro lado
también tiene muchas cosas que harían
las delicias de un pablo iglesias
cualquiera rusia es uno de los pocos
países que mantiene su apoyo
incondicional al régimen de nicolás
maduro en venezuela además su política
económica es lo opuesto al libre mercado
es más algunos artistas de izquierdas
como oliver stone le tienen en un
auténtico pedestal sea como sea por
mucho que le podamos criticar
putin es uno de los líderes mejor
valorados por sus propios ciudadanos
lleva más de 20 años gobernando el país
y mantiene unos índices de aprobación en
torno al 80 por ciento por supuesto que
todo esto viene acompañado de una brutal
represión a cualquiera que le pueda
hacer sombra sin embargo parece que todo
esto está empezando a cambiar
las elecciones locales avergüenzan al
kremlin el partido del gobierno pierde
la mitad de sus escaños en el
ayuntamiento lo sé lo sé en un país como
rusia las elecciones municipales tienen
muy poca importancia pero son la prueba
de que algo está cambiando de repente el
partido de putin rusia unida se ha
convertido en una marca tóxica y sus
candidatos ya no presumen de su cercanía
al gran líder sino que lo ocultan pero
no sólo eso si seguís visual polític
desde hace tiempo recordaréis un vídeo
en el que hablábamos de un tal alexéi
navalni decíamos que naval ni eran
activistas con más posibilidades de
hacer frente a putin pues bien estas
elecciones han demostrado que no
afinamos mal el tiro y que naval ni va a
dar mucho de qué hablar en los próximos
años así que la pregunta de hoy es
estamos ante el principio del fin de
putin porque tantos rusos le están
empezando a dar la espalda a su líder
que está cambiando en rusia hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el nacimiento de una leyenda todos
recordamos el año 1998 porque fue cuando
de spears sacó su primer mega hit pero
esa no fue la única desgracia que
ocurrió ese año mientras todos sufríamos
el hit me baby one more time los rusos
sufrían una crisis de proporciones nacho
vidal ya nash de repente todos los
inversores del país huían y cuando los
inversores sacan su dinero de rusia que
es lo que hacen pues obviamente cambian
sus rublos por la divisa del país donde
quieren dejar sus ahorros las libras
esterlina dólares americanos lo que sea
así que de repente todo el mundo vendía
rublos y casi nadie quería comprarlos el
resultado fue una de las mayores
devaluaciones de la historia de rusia
la noche a la mañana los ciudadanos
comunes vieron como todo su dinero valía
la mitad y si buena parte de la culpa de
este desastre se debía al por entonces
presidente borís y el zinc básicamente y
el sinn fue el encargado de la
transición rusa hacia el capitalismo y
no vamos a entrar en detalles aquí pero
digamos que incluso britney spears lo
habría hecho mejor
a diferencia de república checa o
polonia rusia vendió sus compañías
públicas a grandes oligarcas así que en
lugar de crear un entorno competitivo
donde pudieran surgir empresas
innovadoras el gobierno se limitó a
vivir de los ingresos de su principal y
prácticamente único producto el zumo de
dinosaurios
y en ese sentido el pobre boris yeltsin
tuvo muy mala suerte porque los años 90
los precios del barril de crudo estaban
por los suelos así que era cuestión de
tiempo que la economía se fuera al
traste y así es exactamente como ocurrió
en el año 1998 rusia sufrió una mega
devaluación y un año más tarde
boris y el zinc tuvo que dimitir con
unos resultados de popularidad por los
suelos y aquí es cuando entra el ínclito
el inefable la leyenda la mascota de
visual política aquí es cuando entra
[Música]
yen sin límite nombrando a putin como
presidente en funciones para presentarse
en las elecciones de marzo a falta de un
partido político que apadrinará vladimir
putin decidió presentarse a estas
elecciones como independiente y creedme
esta era la mejor carta de presentación
los partidos liberales habían
decepcionado a los rusos los comunistas
también y putin sólo prometía una cosa
estabilidad asegurar que rusia no
volvería a tener sobresaltos ni
terrorismo checheno nimega de
evaluaciones ni recesiones
y cree en aquel momento en el año 2000
este mensaje era mucho más atractivo que
el ubs y de hecho mientras whitney
spears abrazaba el cambio de siglo con
decenas de discos de platino útil
arrasaba en sus primeras elecciones con
un 53 por ciento del voto para que os
hagáis una idea el siguiente en la lista
era el candidato comunista que ni
siquiera llegó al 30 por ciento así es
como empezó la leyenda de putin poco
después
putin crearía su propio partido rusia
unida que era una fusión de otros
partidos sin ideología concreta es decir
que frente al comunismo de la urss y el
liberalismo fallido de helsinn putin
propone únicamente estabilidad a
cualquier coste y la pregunta es ha
decepcionado putin a los rusos pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
y la historia se repite tan pronto como
putin puso un pie en el kremlin los
precios del petróleo empezaron a subir
como la espuma de repente el gobierno
empezaba a ingresar dinero a paladas
gracias a esto rusia bajó todos los
impuestos a niveles ridículos para que
os hagáis una idea
los rusos ahora mismo pagan un impuesto
de la renta lineal del 13 por ciento y
si habéis oído bien 13% y el estado se
forraba con el dinero de sus petroleras
estos ingresos permitieron que putin
pudiera construir carreteras rascacielos
hospitales
[Música]
de repente los rusos empezaban a vivir
bien y mientras britney spears se pasaba
de moda el resto del mundo aprendimos a
cantar ese mítico mamá luba bailaba y el
problema pues que en lugar de modernizar
la economía rusia se quedó como estaba
putin a cabo con la élite de oligarcas
corruptos y la sustituyó por otra élite
de oligarcas corruptos a día de hoy el
petróleo y el gas natural siguen siendo
el 70 por ciento de sus exportaciones
de hecho conocéis alguna empresa rusa
que venda algo que no sea ni gas ni
petróleo seguramente no y qué pasa
cuando dependes tanto de una única
materia prima pues esto
la mala situación política y económica
están destrozando rusia cuya divisa está
debilitada por la caída en picado del
petróleo y las sanciones de occidente
exacto de nuevo en el momento en el cual
el precio del petróleo cayó la economía
rusa se fue a freír churros si a esto le
sumas la invasión de crimea y las
sanciones económicas tienes lo mismo que
pasó en 1998 huida de capitales y qué
pasa cuando se van los capitales pues
que de nuevo la divisa se devalúa porque
todo el mundo la quiere vender y nadie
la quiere comprar conclusión en cinco
meses el valor del rublo cayó a la mitad
y creedme concretamente esta crisis la
viví muy de cerca porque por aquel
entonces yo compartía piso con un amigo
ruso que se dedicaba a traducir libros
para editoriales de su país de repente
su sueldo cayó en picado es más recuerdo
que en las casas de cambio de praga que
es donde yo vivo por si no lo sabéis no
cambiaban rublos y de nuevo los rusos de
a pie vieron como incluso los alimentos
básicos como un repollo o una barra de
pan duplicaba en su precio de un día
para otro y ya sé lo que estáis pensando
en estos momentos line
de putin está por los suelos verdad pues
nada de eso la popularidad de putin no
dejaba de crecer y todo esto se debe a
dos factores por un lado el kremlin
nunca dejó de hacer propaganda y por el
otro putin se encargó de evitar que
ningún opositor le hiciera sombra
1400 arrestados en una protesta de la
oposición en las elecciones de moscú y
hay que reconocerle las cosas toda esa
represión le ha funcionado durante años
hasta hace muy poco la oposición a putin
era prácticamente inexistente y estaba
totalmente fracturada no había una
ideología ni tampoco un líder claro
hasta ahora ahora es cuando entra en
escena alexéi navalni de nuevo si
lleváis tiempo suscritos a visual
político habréis oído su nombre antes se
trata de un ex abogado que ha creado su
propia plataforma anti corrupción para
que os hagáis una idea su canal de
youtube tiene más de 3 millones de
suscriptores lo cual es una barbaridad
en un país como rusia y aunque no le
hayan dejado presentarse a las
elecciones y haya pasado más tiempo en
la cárcel que britney spears en el bar
naval ni tiene una influencia enorme
sólo necesitaba una causa una causa que
realmente enfadara a los rusos
necesitaba algo más aparte de la
corrupción y esa causa ha sido la subida
de la edad de jubilación
navalny apela a las masas para que
protesten contra la reforma de las
pensiones y os preguntaréis de verdad
son tan importantes estas protestas se
puede traducir en algo a nivel electoral
es ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
un país sin ideologías en estas
elecciones hemos visto como muchos
liberales liberales de esos que
celebraron la caída del telón de acero
han terminado votando al partido
comunista por primera vez en su vida y
diréis porque pues básicamente porque en
rusia ya no hay ideologías sólo existe
el putinismo y todo lo demás en estas
elecciones municipales casi todos los
candidatos que no pertenecían a rusia
unida han sido rechazados por la
comisión electoral y de nuevo todas las
protestas han sido reprimidas por la
policía sin embargo a diferencia de
otras ocasiones la historia ahora es muy
pero que muy distinto
los oficiales rusos intentaron
ridiculizar al van con uno pero sin
embargo le han convertido en un héroe
básicamente y van gol uno es un
periodista que estaba investigando los
escándalos de corrupción del gobierno
como ya viene siendo práctica habitual
por estas tierras por supuesto que la
policía le encontró mágicamente drogas y
le metió en la cárcel porque como ya
sabéis todos si investigas a alguien
cercano a putin mágicamente aparecen
drogas en tu casa o resulta que no pagas
impuestos o que has cometido algún
crimen del que ni siquiera eras
consciente pues bien esta vez ninguna de
estas tácticas ha llegado a funcionar
las protestas han continuado y la
policía rusa se ha visto obligada a
liberar a yvan colonna ofreció el apoyo
al partido de putin ha caído a tal nivel
que los candidatos para el ayuntamiento
de moscú han tenido que tomar una
decisión drástica
los candidatos de rusia unida se
presentarán como independientes en las
elecciones de moscú sin embargo nada de
esto ha servido para mucho alexéi
navalni ha presentado una lista donde se
enmascaraba a todos estos falsos
candidatos independientes y como tiene
tantísimos seguidores esa lista ha sido
una auténtica bomba electoral pero no
sólo eso decíamos antes que la oposición
anti putin siempre ha estado fracturada
o que no podía presentarse a las
elecciones
el propio navalny no ha podido
presentarse como candidato e incluso ha
pasado una nueva temporada en la cárcel
sin embargo pese a todas estas
dificultades este hombre ha conseguido
convencer a sus seguidores para que
hagan algo muy concreto
con la estrategia del voto inteligente
la oposición rusa apunta al partido de
los ladrones corruptos de putin
básicamente esto del smart go team el
bote inteligente consiste en votar al
candidato que tenga más posibilidades de
ganar y que no sea del partido de putin
da igual la ideología el color o el
partido al que pertenezca que en tu
distrito puede ganar un comunista pues
vota lo cualquier cosa es mejor que
alguien de rusia unida y eso explica los
resultados tan buenos que han sacado los
comunistas en el ayuntamiento de moscú
han pasado de tener cinco concejales en
2014 a tener 13 en 2019 vamos que casi
triplican los resultados como os podéis
imaginar esto no significa que de
repente los moscovitas se hayan vuelto
comunistas esto significa que han votado
al candidato que no era del partido de
putin y así es como se ha producido la
gran noticia
[Música]
las protestas del voto inteligente han
dado una bofetada al partido de putin en
las elecciones a ver todavía no se puede
decir que es el fin del putinismo de
hecho el partido de putin seguirá en el
poder en el ayuntamiento de moscú pero
desde luego esta noticia es la primera
vez en la que hemos visto una derrota
electoral para putin y no sólo eso por
fin parece que vemos a un líder político
capaz de hacerle frente
alexéi navalni y ya sé ya sé lo que me
vais a decir cómo se os ve el plumero a
estos de visual política
ya estáis aquí haciendo propaganda de
naval me y lo cierto es que no como
explicábamos hace un año naval ni no es
el clásico político al que apoyaríamos
en este canal de entrada es otro ultra
nacionalista que en varias ocasiones ha
dicho que está en contra de los
inmigrantes y que está a favor de la
anexión de crimea
[Música]
al menos por el momento- navalny no ha
demostrado ni muchísimo menos ser el
liberal que muchos quieren ver en él
pero como ya sabéis en este canal os
contamos lo que pasa no lo que nos
gustaría que pasara y lo que está
pasando ahora mismo es que un señor
incluso estando en la cárcel ha sido
capaz de convencer a millones de rusos
para que hagan un voto protesta creo que
es algo bastante remarcable así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
estamos ante el principio del fin de
putin llegaremos a ver como naval ni
llega a disputarle el trono y en caso de
que ganara terminaremos viendo más de lo
mismo o tal vez naval ni sea capaz de
cambiar el sistema ruso podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a visual político y dadle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]